Poland's ruling Christian nationalist party,
law and justice,
called Beast for short,
remains the biggest party in parliament
after last night's election results.
And yet the news is really bad for them.
That's because they don't have the
allies to form a government
that would have a backing of the majority of lawmakers.
With 200 projected seats,
according to exit polls,
Beast needs to find 31 seats elsewhere
to get a majority of parliaments.
And the only even remotely possible ally
is the far right libertarian Confederatea party.
But they did far worse than expected,
with only 12 projected seats. That means
the second biggest party is likely to come to power.
That's the civic coalition of former
European Council President and former Polish PM
Donald Tusk,
who despite only having 163 projected seats,
far less than pieces 200.
When combined with the 55 seats of tezieroga,
the centre right Third Way party,
and the 30 seats of the Social Democrats in Leviza,
these guys right here,
they arrive at a comfortable 248 seats,
which is 17 more than they need.
This is a huge win for the EU
in a substantial setback
for the growing far right movement in Europe.
So follow for more.